um
so one of the most
counterintuitive
ideas
is the idea
of cyber daleks
the idea that there's a connection a
relationship between psychedelics
and cybernetics
even though psychedelics are more
associated with spiritual experiences
and transcendence of the self
and cybernetics is associated with
computers or technological hardware the
truth is that
psychedelics and cybernetics are
intimately intertwined
in fact there was an article once that
called google the first psychedelically
informed superpower
so from where
does this idea originate that where what
is the
what is the origin story right what for
the seeds of of the intersection of
psychedelics and cybernetics well for
this you have to go back to the 1960s in
silicon valley you know the bay area
near san francisco we were in the middle
of the psychedelic revolution everybody
was tuning in turning on dropping out
the whole thing was happening people
were
obliterating their limiting beliefs and
their sense of self you know i think
timothy leary said you experience the
fresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on your nerve
endings but what happens is that when
engineers
and other technologists and material
thinkers and mathematicians had these
ecstatic experiences their interpretive
frameworks were more technical rather
than seeing the grade beyond some
evidence of a spiritual realm they
realize we already live in a world
that's infinitely mysterious where
forces are at play that we cannot see we
cannot touch we cannot smell and we
cannot see
right and so from then they realize if
we can free our minds from our limiting
beliefs maybe we can free ourselves
through our technical proficiency in
similar ways to the degree that now our
ideas can be recorded in silica the
contents of our minds can be
exteriorized our tools and technologies
are engineering miracles right they are
they are a reflection of what timothy
leary or rather terence mechanic called
the coral reef-like animal right the
human being has become the extruder of
technological material can you get any
more psychedelic than that we take in
matter of low organization it goes
through the filters of the human mind
then we extrude space shuttles and
iphones we engender complexity we rework
materials so that a hunk of junk becomes
an iphone a device made of plastic and
metal that can communicate us with minds
across the planet we can bring a musical
soundscape you know a perfect song to
frame a moment that seems to be showered
by the sky we can summon the song we can
direct it into being like a dream
we can craft our waking dreams and
mediate our own realities we have
uploaded ourselves into a matrix only to
reveal that we already live in a matrix
that can be programmed through our
technical proficiency
and the digital revolution and the
virtual revolution is spilling over into
the biotechnological revolution and then
we're going to be patterning biology
which is also software right which is
also a subversively psychedelic idea
that all is programmable and everything
can be upgraded and everything can be
retuned and everything can be
transformed and then nanotechnology
which sees the material world as
programmable atoms another psychedelic
idea so when leary said you experience
the fresh the hardly bearable ecstasy of
direct energy exploding on your nerve
endings that has been made manifest by
digital technology virtual metaversus
biotechnological mrna vaccines and
eventually nanotechnology creating
buildings that self-assemble we are
living in a magical world
and if you could time-lapse human
progress it would look like our minds
our consciousnesses the imagination is
spilling out of us and we are
actualizing the human imagination we are
designing the world and ourselves into
being right we are literally a thinking
stratum of the earth that is willing
itself into existence but that's already
what biology is so it's biology becoming
aware of itself which is also a
psychedelic insight when tim doody said
that psychedelic experiences
recontextualizes the self and makes us
realize that we are
um recontextualizes the self into a
marvelous conduit in a timeless hole we
are a marvelous conduit in a timeless
hole from which molecules and meanings
flow from neurons to nebula and back
again in ones and zeros in dna code and
in programmable atoms my friends and
that's
what makes the technological revolution
and singularity we're living through
psychedelic it is psychedelic it's
cybernetics cybernetics is where
psychedelics and cyberdelics is where
psychedelics and cybernetics meet that's
the cyberdelic revolution in the world
we live in today
[Music]